alright y'all so thirsty Thursday and
this is a term that usually you know
when I met the show and life is normal
and not pandemic version I'm sitting in
sipping some alcohol with you find
people online and today I have invited
well today River you wanted to come hang
out with us right she won't keep say hi
hi what are you doing right now pop did
you say you are making out with your
family right now
what did you say what's your thinking
cuz we're not doing that but what you
spit out you're hanging out yeah okay
making out something different we'll
talk about it so anyway what are we
drinking today honey oh you want your
hat it scroll the Pendleton sage pills
insane yeah she's really good with a lot
of piltan mm-hmm a splash of water okay
a splash of sprite okay that's what you
got it's really good this is a really
good drink and brought to you by Val
actually gave us these the kid this is
Remy's and that's rivers I'm drinking
I'm drinking my alcoholic might get
scooped up that's what we've come to and
reverends drinking some kid champagne if
you will do you like your kitchen pain
yes oh it doesn't mix well with your
your candy cane yeah okay well let's put
it on the ground so to hold it you only
can't on the ground you drink this
all right she's been dying for that
candy cane all right so today for
Thirsty Thursday I found out my team and
talk show I'm in digital world wanted me
to play game called last time I is that
what it's called last uh last time I so
we're hanging out we're hiding from our
13-year old and our almost four year old
our four year old is me right now he's
kind of tough right now very tough
Remy is very tough he uses words like I
don't love you go away that's super nice
and his defense he was kind of
quarantine two weeks before everybody
had to be according cuz he got really
sick so he had to be at home for like
two weeks from grab I mean he has been a
cords you forever right now so he's
losing as much anyway but we're gonna
play I really like this drink we're
gonna play under memories last time I
and I have never seen these so you
branded these are asking questions I
mean before the pandemic the first one
is baked I mean I could cry literally
last night consisted of we ran home
because we were it was kind of late it
but it stays light here forever in
Montana and kind of lose track of time
and I was like oh god I get kids to bed
we hadn't eaten yet so Brandon had the
grand idea of doing breakfast for dinner
which I love so I ran home while y'all
were finishing stuff up the ranch he and
Seth and the two little ones I had
debated them
I was cooking breakfast for dinner at
the same time which if you know
breakfast fits are very quick so you
really can't run from the oven and then
or the stove as well so I was running
all over the place so I did biscuits
eggs bacon gravy baked ones let me think
something
thank you oh but I need you mother
I was listening member that I've got
just made you blueberry muffins too
can you take his shower tonight please
Oh like you did last night yeah instead
of a bath yeah yeah I love Li Shan I
want to be based okay the next question
brushed and animals hair um the last of
my brush and animals hair I mean I don't
know if my fingers count but I always
that was just like this morning Henry
I have a golden doodle named Henry he's
Blackie great he's awesome his name
tower was our oldest dog and he died and
was really sad
yeah karma passed away he had a really
long life though right thank you
Oh greedy bastards who she had a really
long life yeah yeah but what yeah well
we don't have to name every one that's
died okay let's go to the next chance
case like this one played in the snow
played in the snow
yeah every time we try it's hard to get
it packed or whatever we didn't do that
though there's tons of snow up here um
well the last time I played in the snow
that's pretty much every day here is it
snows every day here really - oh yeah
[Music]
last time I laughed so hard I grabbed
that was last night because I found out
I'm doing a smear campaign for my new
single I dare you and I recorded it in
six different languages with different
artists and beautiful nuggets of
surprises keep coming out and all my
stuff that I phonetically spelled it's
where I could sing it a little easier
for me like quickly in the studio is in
LA and we're in Montana so I've had to
completely redo that and I did that last
night and at one point I just started
laughing so hard I was crying because it
was 238 I remember the time in the
morning this morning and I was and then
you would come home from trying to chase
all coyotes because
try to get baby cats no all right this
is every day in a movie forget the movie
or the TV show commercials I was I just
especially when you have kid I was like
oh my god Oh car right now thinking
about it I can't even like you start
playing you know okay I'll start crying
I'm very touched
I broke a sweat mmm Oh broke okay that
would be that would be on the treadmill
or no I was doing Tracy Anderson I can't
use the stop no I've been doing these
Tracy Anderson workouts and that little
athletic fairy she's out to get me
she wants to kill me oh my god she's so
great and like her videos so work but oh
my gosh my I was getting charley horses
everywhere especially Mike but anyway
that's playing something that was like
yesterday so the thing is it turns on my
workout in pandemics but I also eat our
entire kitchen alright still really
proud this probably goes with that
Burton the last questions broke a sweat
but I you know what I felt really proud
because the other day or when I was
saying like last night when I was
working on that multiple languages I
that was a really hard thing like I just
thought you know I grew up singing
different languages and I thought it
would be so cool to do this and then it
was way harder especially with the the
Hebrew and the Arabic love seeing in
it's just a really cool I love all
different languages but anyway that
would put yeah but that was probably I
was proud that I actually that came to
fruition and are as a team we all made
that happen that's a big task a good
global task thank you we haven't been
breakfast we've bought here Montana a
while back and I wasn't going to be able
to not open yet it's not open it will be
open for watch because we're gonna have
to live in it while we're building a
house but we bought it it's so cute it's
right in like the drum part of
Phillipsburg Montana it's so cute and
anyway we I was gonna have to hire
somebody to help us do it because I
didn't have time because of all the jobs
but then you know this happened so I've
been up all day tonight decorating with
Wayfair cuz I have anyway Caroline so I
wait for it I've been working on
decorating the whole that's kind of the
cracking it's a lot of work it's fun but
it's a lot of work to make everything
cohesive and anyway and work so I've
been doing that I've been decorating I
did get a thing that we're about to do
crochet it's like this little kit where
river and I can crochet we're kind of
living out of this small cabin right now
so we don't have a ton of stuff out so
we're four-wheeler and river can take
Remy on rides on her four-wheeler with a
little brother knock you brother change
step and ready yep any of a sister named
Slovenia she loves to ride horsies she
does you do you did really well in your
worst lessons you like riding snacks
don't you it's not you here she's okay
the last time you want to get actually
clue
and it wasn't the first time I use
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
shooting some stuff for my TV show and I
was running back up to the house because
I was like okay wait I do need a coat
it's really cold and there are so many
like little you know the ground is that
even it's a Tundra appearance so I hit a
hole in my left ankle it feels better
though
but I rolled my ankles at the time
you're talking about was there another
time I am a little clumsy I think it's I
I have a hard time focusing
that's right X my mom was this morning
um yeah that sucks my mom pretty daily
family yeah grandma
my mom is yeah your grandma but she's my
mom whose album what are you blown away
oh I love Selena Gomez
I'm with Randall and ringing and there's
a lot of great songs on that not sure
what what am I even talking about
exactly
oh do you but you know we do like trolls
we like the neutral soundtrack I love
that just sing song guys can he's not
fighting again okay okay I want you to
listen to when's the last time you felt
grateful now he let in the other
I learned a candy cane it's a large
candy cane she said was gonna take her
all day to eat and I was like or months
it's enormous
the last time I was grateful honestly it
was this morning I was telling River it
was like even if she was kind of feeling
a little trash can we go to LA or can we
go to Tennessee su-22 go somewhere else
you were a central liar anyway and I
said hey we got to be grateful and why
don't we be grateful because we're
really lucky everybody's kind of trapped
wherever they are and we're lucky we
have a ranch so we can like kind of run
around on here and not good yes all
right last question okay laughter
something your kids did every day she's
River is let's get a starter on show the
river oh sure she's been doing videos
with our Nene Ally when I'm working
she'll do videos I didn't know and she
said she's had done a couple videos now
we're gonna share on them and she kids
we're gonna start sharing a but she she
sent him she was so sorry that the snick
miss was happening instead of sickness
she gives makes Nikolas it was awesome
and I laughed really hard she was saying
I'd like to show you the ocean and the
ocean happens to be a Creek and she said
she
she went from hosting to producing and
said show the ocean and when I said it's
saying I'm sorry Edie Creek Ali Chris
Peter it's it's a river and I was like
watching the video and I was like
actually it's a creek or Creek they call
it that um anyway but way hey we're
making the best of it right watching
movies you get to plan take walks are
you gonna graduate four wheeler your
horse riding lessons kids would love to
beat your shoes right now
you know yeah I want your life all right
yeah no all right well we know we did I
feel like we know that I love that we're
on a bathroom together that's the best
part
people liked me in the bathroom the
first one and the bathtub and I was like
okay we'll just do it here again and
then Brandon has been doing these foods
negative producing all over the lands
they doing so so he sat down with me and
then River wanted to join so today was a
family affair in the bathtub yeah with
the boys at home a real country all
right these are from Montana State
they've been healthy all right we're
gonna fly the curve okay I'm sorry
sickness is going around but stay safe
as your family and have a great I'm
great day right now and oh I'll buy a
sweet subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going